If you've seen Avengers: Endgame, now's a
good time to start unpacking exactly how the
MCU will cope with its losses, what those
deaths mean for our heroes, and how future
stories will be affected.
If you haven't seen the film yet, consider
this your first, second, and final warning:
Major spoilers ahead!
Marvel's Infinity Saga started with Tony Stark,
so it's only fitting that it ends with him.
If Tony Stark had to die, we're glad he got
to go out the way he did.
After declaring "I am Iron Man" right in Thanos'
face, he snaps the Mad Titan and his whole
army from existence.
Of course, everyone is absolutely devastated
in the aftermath of Tony's death, as we see
at the funeral for the Armored Avenger.
Pretty much every surviving superhero was
in attendance, and it's clear that the loss
will echo throughout the community for years
to come, particularly when it comes to those
closest to him, like Peter Parker and Nick
Fury.
And then there's Tony's family.
Happy Hogan is clearly stepping in to be a
kind of father figure to Morgan Stark, promising
to buy her all the cheeseburgers she wants,
but Pepper Potts' grief will run deeper.
After years of worrying about him, she could
see that Tony really was at peace after ending
his own personal curse.
Still, she'll miss him every day, even if
we never see this portrayed in future films.
Black Widow was one of the MCU's great survivors.
She faced down countless superpowered threats
and personal demons throughout her life, and
at least her death was on her own terms.
"This is gonna work, Steve."
"I know it is.
'Cause I don't know what I'm gonna do if it
doesn't."
Natasha Romkanoff chose to sacrifice herself
so that her fellow Avengers could get on with
their lives.
As she said all along: She had red in her
ledger, and this was the ultimate way of wiping
that out.
Sadly, Natasha didn't get a funeral, at least
not that we saw.
Her death came during the Avengers' epic time
heist, and we saw the grief in the faces of
her comrades as they swore to make her loss
worth it.
Beyond the emotional loss, there's also a
greater loss for the MCU.
In the face of everything, Natasha was always
the cool one under pressure.
She became the field commander for the Avengers
in the years after the Decimation, and the
point of contact for heroes all over the galaxy.
Now someone else will need to fill her shoes,
and it'll be hard to find someone who's up
to the task.
Tony Stark is gone, but the technology he
brought into the world is not.
His inventions have heavily impacted the MCU,
and two other superheroes proudly wear his
tech: There's War Machine and now there's
Pepper Potts, who suits up in her own armor,
taking on an identity that Marvel Comics calls
"Rescue."
Though it's unlikely that Gwyneth Paltrow
will return to the MCU, War Machine will probably
still be knocking around.
And Stark's Iron Man suits won't be going
anywhere in the public imagination, particularly
after he saved the world in such spectacular
fashion.
With that in mind, it might be time to call
up a young scientist to fill Stark's shoes
and take flight in his suits.
In the comics, there's a teenager named Riri
Williams, who wears Stark-style armor and
calls herself "Ironheart."
Some fans have speculated that Black Panther's
little sister Shuri could take on this particular
mantle in the MCU.
But perhaps it'll be Stark's daughter Morgan,
or a character haven't spent much time with.
Whatever the case, the MCU is ripe for new
blood, and Ironheart could lead the charge.
"Maybe."
With his last act of heroism, Tony Stark not
only killed Thanos, but wiped away every last
trace of his minions and soldiers, ridding
the universe of its greatest threat.
In the first Avengers film, the character
known only as the Other gave Thanos a sharply-worded
warning about fighting the heroes of Earth.
"To challenge them is to court death."
Thanos simply smiled at the words, which is
so Thanos, and, at the time, it seemed like
a wink to the audience members who knew that
comic book Thanos had a massive crush on the
bony lady known as Death, and he literally
wanted to court her.
But now that Endgame has come and gone, and
the Other's warning has been proven with the
death of Thanos, that only heightens the cosmic
reputation of the Earth and its heroes.
There's a whole universe out there, and it
all went through the Decimation.
As everyone recovers, word will spread of
the heroes of Earth and how they were the
key to undoing all of Thanos' work.
That means future supervillains are even more
likely to fear Earth.
It also means there's a massive power vacuum
that used to be filled with Thanos and his
minions.
Yes, the universe's greatest threat is gone,
but power vacuums have to be filled on both
sides of the good and evil divide.
Somewhere out there, some madman or madwoman
is hellbent on destruction, eager to get a
taste of the Avengers and prove they can beat
them.
As Vision said, this kind of power is bound
to invite confrontation.
As part of the entrance of Riri Williams as
Ironheart in the Marvel Comics universe, it
was revealed that Tony Stark sustained such
serious injuries in the Civil War II event
that he fell into a coma.
But he conveniently made a copy of his consciousness
beforehand, which was able to assist Riri
and freely chat with other Marvel characters
as a form of artificial intelligence.
This Tony Stark A.I. became a mainstay of
the Marvel Universe, and retained all the
wit and wisdom that characterized Tony.
Tony's last recording for his daughter is
just that, a recording.
But considering everything Tony has tinkered
with over the years, including frequent artificial
intelligence ventures, it's quite possible
that he would have taken a cue from his comics
counterpart and found some way to record himself
as a consciousness.
"Hey Miss Potts, if you find this recording,
don't feel bad about this."
This would allow the character to carry on
in some form, and it would create opportunities
for Robert Downey Jr. to continue making cameos
in any upcoming MCU projects.
Tony Stark the man would be gone, but Tony
Stark the artificial intelligence could live
on... if only as a voice in another hero's
head.
And an extremely sassy voice, at that.
"We're going out of town."
"Okay, we've been through this, nope."
"Yup.
"The man says no."
"Immediately and indefinitely."
"Honey."
"Great idea."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.